Você acha que está saudável só porque os
seus exames de sangue estão normais?
Pois veja só o que a ciência está
descobrindo. Estudos recentes mostram
que os alimentos ultraprocessados podem
estar causando dano no seu DNA muito
antes de qualquer alteração aparecer nos
exames tradicionais. Pesquisadores
analisaram mulheres que consumiam cerca
de 45% das calorias diárias vindas de
ultraprocessados encontraram alterações
em mais de 80 regiões do genoma. E olha
só, isso aconteceu mesmo em pessoas com
peso considerado normal. Veja bem,
existe um mecanismo chamado metilação do
DNA, que funciona como interruptor dos
seus genes. Ele decide quais genes ficam
ligados e quais ficam desligados. Quando
você consome muitos ultraprocessados,
esse sistema começa a falhar. Genes que
deveriam proteger você contra o câncer,
contra o acúmulo de gordura e contra a
resistência à insulina podem ser
silenciados e genes prejudiciais podem
ser ativados. Um estudo com mais de
3.000 crianças encontrou alterações
semelhantes afetando tireoide, fígado e
reparo celular. Então o recado é claro.
Seu corpo pode estar sofrendo por
dentro, mesmo quando parece tudo bem por
fora. pensar o que você coloca no seu
prato é proteger sua saúde no nível mais
profundo que existe.